first thing that comes to mind is he's
actually the reason why I quit my
business yes oh yeah what's that believe
nation we are trying something new today
a vlog style where you're gonna follow
me around on my busy day hopefully get
inspired see what I do on a day to day
basis and we'll see if this test work
set
I'm just so nervous and excited yeah
[Music]
for nine hours please that's not a
normal day though we'd start getting
ready around 10:00 10:00 10:30 10 no B
you should be in bed at 10:30
really damn hey guys listen up 10 we get
ready for bad take chemo I'll brush your
teeth all that stuff going down and then
we're usually up 7 so I started YouTube
I don't know probably open 9 years ago
long ago something like that I don't
really I don't really look backwards
that much I'm not I'm not fantastic at
remembering dates and what I did before
but around 9 years maybe 10 years I'm
seriously probably four years I think
everyone should try YouTube video just
to see just know it's like in the past
four years has grown from
7000 subscribers up to 1.3 million
just by making content every single day
just four years of making two to three
videos every single day and sucking I
was an introvert I still am an introvert
it doesn't come out that I am I don't
have to Nina knows I don't talk to
people at parties I hate people I love
people
I think people give up too soon I think
people make the video and it's not
fantastic and now they think well I'm
not
you know I made 350 videos before I
wasn't completely embarrassed by my
couldn't watch my videos back without
being massively embarrassed by it and it
took me to 750 videos before I inspired
myself yeah I looked at the video like
and that was pretty good that was clean
which that's crisp but 750 videos before
I inspired myself and 350 until I wasn't
just absolutely embarrassed and most
people they just gave up too soon it
wasn't big when I started and I didn't
have ambitions to be a YouTube celebrity
either
she was just it was a thing there are
people who are taking off but it wasn't
really part of my ambition to be
it wasn't definitely definitely not as
big as it is right now or anywhere close
none of my friends are doing YouTube
there wasn't something that people
there was no clear way to make money
doing it
it really just started as a labor of
love to help entrepreneurs because when
I started my first business it was such
a struggle
emotionally financially too but
emotionally that it was among the worst
days of my life and I just wanted to
make it easier for other people not to
have to deal with all the suffering that
I did my son lives most of the time with
my ex-wife I picked him up on Tuesdays
and weekends and long weekends and PA
days and all that stuff but we make sure
to check in every day on on a call just
to see what's up before he goes to
school hello hello can you hear me all
right good
what was the song airplane oh I know the
song okay you got to put at 1.25 hey are
you are you posting are you post
anything on your Instagram today what
what's the message let's hear it no I
didn't check you hadn't posted yet when
I checked have confidence what do you
say about confidence you're gonna make
you watch today okay okay that's fine
okay mister I'm gonna get on the highway
okay have a great day love you mister
bye Hayden is almost 9
it's it's every year is better at least
for me
we could have had a phone conversation a
year ago trying to keep the attention
span for an eight-year-old can be
challenging he's he's just gotten into
Instagram last week he has a private
account so you can't you can't follow
him or see what he's doing but he posts
his own little videos every morning
talking about confidence or something
else it's pretty good there's obviously
some influences that he's watching what
I'm doing and wants to do some of it for
himself but I'm always in the back of my
head not pushing him to do the things
that I do I want to involve him in my
life and in my work and he loves being
on the videos and we do vlogs or if he's
home from school but I think the best
thing that my parents gave me is one the
belief in myself that whatever I set my
mind to I'd be able to do and two they
never push me to do the thing that they
wanted to do so my dad worked for the
government for most of his life and then
became a consultant
there was a lawyer and did a whole bunch
of other things too
neither those paths for all three of us
I've sisters one older one younger all
of us did totally different things and
think that was really great with all the
entrepreneur's I deal with one of the
biggest things they have challenge with
is dealing with their parents who want
them to do something else than what they
actually under themselves and it's toxic
and I got what point are you gonna
decide that this is your life
you know when you're 5 years old you
don't have a choice you know Hayden
doesn't have much of a choice but when
you're 18 when you're 20 24 like how how
late do you leave it until you decide
that I'm gonna do my life right if
you're 40 he's still gonna do the thing
that your parents want you to do so at
some point you have to decide you know
I'm gonna do my version even though that
what the parents are giving you is out
of love it's all love for the most part
it's love they just see success
differently than you do so what I am
trying to do with my son is the same
path where whatever he wants to do you
go out and do it and you can crush it
he loves to draw I suck at drawing
but we'll spend time drawing drawing
characters drawing animals drawing
nature I sit down and do that with him
because if that's where he wants to go
then I want him to be I think you're
happiest when you're doing the thing
that you love doing and I think a lot of
times parents stifle
creativity I prevent the kids from doing
what they actually are meant to do so
we've got a little bit of time we're
gonna go up I have to meet with my
assistant online then alex is coming
over at 9:30 and doing a YouTube
interview live on the channel then
you
to meetings
come on
[Music]
we got Teemo because he's a therapy dog
so he's three Porter's Shih Tzu 1/4
poodle
we like to because of the therapy this
of it and he said okay well then we have
the trainees not to be dependent so that
he always wants to be around you
this means really hard thing because I
hate training dependency I'd like I
teach humans to the exact opposite I
want you to be your friend and let you
do your own thing don't be like a dog I
love following my fans and seeing what
they're up to and trying to surprise
them not enough of my fans you guys come
on go live go alive on Instagram so I
could join you
so I'm following now a couple thousand
four thousand people every day were
following more and more and more and
more those are the most active fans but
most of you guys aren't going live
enough so I always see you guys up your
content game circle in live so I can
follow you angles it just stands I
bounce I've been using the stand up desk
for I don't know wait before was popular
part of the fog like kills energy I
think it's sitting all day and all day
long I'm just this is how I work
[Music]
[Music]
so I've been working with Evan for the
last two years now I've had the great
fortune of having him as my mentor it's
been amazing I have never had someone
believe in me and pushed me so hard to
be confident myself but be humble at the
same time everyone was part of TDS he
owns TDS and so I joined as a school I
tried to school the dance quit years ago
as a student I mean I had three career
paths of mine it's gonna be a marriage
counselor
cop and then I'd be can't I wanted to
sales and the process of that I was
dancing
just as a side thing and then it just it
just so happened that I started trying
to be a teacher part-time and then he
saw some talented me he's like I think
he'd be amazing and running the dance
school and so that was two years ago
when he offered it to me
Wow I feel like I should get a cake or
something am I gonna get a cake I know
that but feel like I should I don't know
fans know this but he will he will get
so involved like if he cares about
someone like if he finds out someone
within his ecosystem is playing subpar
in their life and he cares about them he
will lose sleep and I remember times
where he's gotten physically sick like
from anxiety of wanting to help the
person and how they're holding
themselves back like I have never seen
that insane level of obsession and love
for wanting people to break free from
their own limitations I don't know if as
I've seen this but Evan could be pretty
funny like I don't know I don't know if
you've seen it so far but he can be a
pretty funny guy cuz I think that when
people watch videos of him probably he's
like the raw raw raw kind of like
intense kind of guy but he's got a yeah
he's got a funny side
I what's the bet they'll know is he's a
really good dancer like when you think
of someone who just functions on the
level of like entrepreneurship and a
hard work and all that kind of stuff
he's a really really good dancer
so if you ever have a chance to come to
the studio see him dance with his wife
Mina you'd be like wow okay that's
that's um Kiki's bringing good times all
right done the beating down let's go see
you what alex is up - what's up what's
cooking good looking all good you have a
coffee yeah good times man listen okay
you're killing me here
I'm not killing it you cannot even the
lobby myself that's how it is very true
no because I was like you know what he's
waking up in the morning you know I want
to go get Starbucks and I need to deal
with some horns and uh and how my car is
like a huge mess of coffee right now
because of the poor quality of the lids
they stop talking I'm not complaining I
got the house I'm already sitting here
man complaining anyone can go save the
drama for your llama you should be the
mama for the moment okay drama loan so
Alex did you do stuff what's happening
here did you introduce yourself it was
interesting because they asked me what
what are some things that people don't
know about you oh yeah yeah
and so I told him how we're not around
like you would some of those hit me
right if I step out of line when he's
around - yeah like thank you very much
usually it's with a phone book so you
know my family doesn't see the bruises
no no nobody buys that I mean I have a
phone number actually to be honest no
but I said no no that would that would
never happen
what he does is I don't know if you know
he published a book my one word he hit
some nerves out my one word it's not oh
my god all your stories here on one word
well my one word but your one word
yeah
I'm gonna get so much heat from your
fronts for this patient yes we need a
lot something UT we did like this
totally hazard a week same high school
right let's make it why that hey you
know okay they have contacts for you
yeah yeah I run I run the damn school
right we started we started two years
ago working together you hired me to run
it and to do the operations for it and
you've been my mentor you with my friend
and you know you don't appreciate me as
much as I feel like you can I did share
with them I did share with the fact that
like I've seen you lose sleep and
physically get sick of how much you care
about people and most people don't see
that side of you okay and oh so I told
them that like I'm like Evan is actually
pretty funny like like if you watch
there's a lot of it is really like rah
rah rah and you don't mean it to your
humerus but if you spend enough time
with Evan like he's a pretty funny guy
and all right most pretty good dancer I
was like it's like like you gotta watch
them dance with Nina
his wife okay and you watched me you'd
be like wow he's got some moves which
surprised me as well to be honest why I
always I always need someone who's very
you know rational and kind of that mode
of thinking necessarily wouldn't be some
the more on the artistic side which is
limited thinking see like you know what
it is it's he doesn't hit me but I wish
he would because it's the shame and
disappointment that hurts me more on a
core level than this then does the
physical abuse of the wallet oh my god
geez
it's not the Alex show yeah okay well
listen they're they're here to see the
full ass I'm a big part of your life and
so they need to see that it's true it's
very true you spend I spent a lot of
time a lot of time with me I know I say
this a big part of my life okay
trees aside Alex come on we got work to
do in tonight alex has to give a quick
speech two minutes beginning two minutes
at the end have a theme for the day and
that's how we always start and end off
our classes so the point of this
discussion here is to help them refine
what is he going to talk about what's
the message for the class what's the
impact that he wants to have on the
students so that when they leave this
class yes they've learned some salsa
moves or better dancers but they're
better human beings because of it as
well and that impact ripples out to
their entire life so everything we're
doing here from Mimi for however long is
is for a two minute good speech is gonna
be given at the front of the class but
that vibe is critical because if people
don't feel moved emotionally and fast
then they're just going to walk out
having learned the dance move to pencil
today's question is what was one time
you let yourself be vulnerable because
of that you grew stronger okay
and so I'm soon for the whole story so
I'm just go for it let's do it let's do
it do a lot I think that I think that
strengths and I think that strength of
mobility are two sides of the same coin
so when I got my operation them to
prevent my hands were sweating and so
the students know about this as a side
note but when I got my patients to put
my hands from sweating one of the first
people outside of my immediate family I
told was the owner that was evident and
so for before that I was struggling in a
long time with a lot of shame and
discomfort because I felt like as an
instructor to inspire people I have to
be perfect I have to be strong I can't
be fallible and if I share something
like that as a weakness how can I tell
people to be strong because like I did
an operation I took the easy way out to
have stop my hands from sweating so when
I told the owner he told me said you
gotta tell it in class and I'm like hi I
I have a script like fear and I just
told you about this thing that nobody
else pretty much knows and you're
telling me now I got to go announce in
the class they said that's on class
because you have that's a leader you
have to create a safe space for people
to feel that they can open themselves
they won't feel that they can open
themselves if you don't open yourself up
so you got to be vulnerable you gotta
let yourself be vulnerable the first
sentence this has to be a powerful
opinion I thought okay I thought it was
okay but maybe I might be fine I think
that okay loner ability and strength the
two sides at the same point yeah it is
that yeah but what is that
me but so he said this is this is this
is where this is where I'm not sure but
because I was considering going from
statement to explanation to story or I
go statement story moral explanation
like the more the moral of the story and
all that if you had to leave if they
have to walk away with one sentence
understanding what came out of it should
be the first sentence okay let me let me
work this through strength strength
means how do you want to fit the pieces
together how's it all going to make
sense did you do on the camera sorry you
can do that paper yeah I'm sweating
right now so much get my hand my hands
can't sweat because I got an operation
body's sweating a lot right now
[Music]
so every Thursday I go live on my
youtube-channel it's my chance to spend
time with the community usually for but
an hour answering as many many many
questions as I can it's my way of giving
back and helping people out and so we're
gonna hop on the live interview and
hopefully helps mantra nurse what's up
YouTube welcome to another YouTube live
happy to be here every Thursday try to
make the commitment to be with you once
a week to answer questions help you with
your business so join on in gave me some
questions this is an AMA format whatever
is on your mind I want to be able to
help with today I'm also vlogging so
I've got a vlogging crew with me and
they're behind the scenes you can't
actually see them they're like right
there and right there so I want to help
you out I want to give you some guidance
as we normally do on Thursdays so come
into the chat I see bunch people join in
and already welcome positive Academy
welcome Lilly you guys can say hi I love
the highs but most importantly I want to
get to your questions so connecting with
with fans I think it's super important I
think every business and any frames our
customers to like every business you
have to connect with the customers I
think that you have to do it in a way
that that is authentic to you I love I
love love love my fans more than I
should I spend more time more than his
ROI positive I think every comment on my
youtube channel should get a response
it's a crazy idea that most youtubers
don't do at least a bigger one that's
easy when it's small and you get five
comment today but when you're getting a
hundred a day how do you respond to all
of them while you build a team and you
respond
I love making myself accessible and open
as much as possible like some people may
say it's not enough I do my best every
day to go live on YouTube or Instagram
to be around my audience and helping
them grow I think it comes down to a
personal decision I remember meet an
author super successful author in New
York City I was there for the weekend he
was there for the weekend we met for
breakfast and I asked him what what does
the rest of your day look like he's like
I'm eating you and then I'm gonna go
back to my room and and write and think
about what I'm gonna do next and he said
how about you
like I'm I'm meeting you then I'm
meeting some friends for lunch and then
and then I'm meeting some more friends
for coffee somewhere else and I'm gonna
spend time with friends for dinner and
then we're gonna go out salsa dance with
other friends at night it's like the
whole day if I'm traveling and I don't
have my wife or my son with me I'm with
fans I love it I love people to meet new
people and help them and he said that
sounds exhausting I couldn't imagine
doing that
and so it's not it's not a judgement
call that what I'm doing is right what
he's doing is wrong
it's just a difference of styles like
I'm gonna win based off of community and
the love and the vibe where other people
might be able to win by just their
intellect or their amazing invention but
I think in general the more you care
about your customers and in the social
media context your your friends the more
ultimately you're gonna have people who
are cheering for you and we're going to
support you to help you build the thing
you want to build
all right we are live and I am fired up
Evans bouncing on a trampoline this is
gonna be a crazy call welcome
this is Peter Boog I founder of the
prestigious game-changers Academy and
thanks for tuning in to our monthly
millionaire video series where we
interview the world's most elite and
successful entrepreneurs CEOs
entertainers in real game changers
people that I personally have massive
respect for and people not just making a
difference in their industry but in the
world so I'm extremely excited for the
value that this call is gonna bring and
of course it's my good friend so I'm
excited to just chop it up and have a
good conversation but Evans obsessed
with helping entrepreneurs with the goal
of reaching the 1 billion you will
socket it again the it's part of
anything when you first start learning
to swim you suck at swimming you're
gonna you would drown if you were thrown
into the deep end and that's ok no
matter how great a message you have or
how good on camera you've been expected
to be really bad at the beginning expect
no comments no feedback and just keep
going when you have a targeted audience
you don't have to be big you just have
to be really well-known in a niche so if
you are the mompreneur person or if you
are the Smurf person or you are the
Cabbage Patch Kids person or you are the
the Porsche SUV person like whatever the
thing is if you are that person and well
known in the industry there are people
whose jobs it is to find you people at
big brands
looking for influencers for a certain
space but if you're too vanilla and
you're playing in a much bigger pond
they're not gonna give you the attention
that you need you heard it first from
the trampoline evans spittin massive
fire all love man I appreciate you
thanks again let me know if there's
anything I could do for you and I look
forward to connecting again soon
all good Thank You Man much love thanks
so much I appreciate it
all right done next going to meet an
entrepreneur be interviewed by a blogger
meet somebody on my team watch out this
class they have an entrepreneur
continues
[Music]
I'm using luminous medicine exercise
programs okay fellow ha you know eight
different apps and all these amazing
products but yeah we kind of put all of
our eggs in that basket yeah on enough
in the category warden okay ask it right
and I hired a bunch of social media
experts right right come to find out
basically entails somebody having an
active Facebook at correct and right at
high school there's a really big lack of
quality information on the platforms
that are most relevant right now to
people
YouTube Instagram Facebook even LinkedIn
media there's a lack of quality content
I got I was on a call just before coming
here with the the person who runs a lot
of the campaigns for Tony Robbins
gaybraham david bach like all of these
yeah old-school big-name people yeah so
we you know gave him david baca okay
know them all great so I had them both
on my youtube channel doing an interview
and people in my audience Hussein Lutz
who says Jay guy I love them he's great
oh and like David boxing thing he sold
ten million books but nobody knows who
he is
Yeah right now now but this whole entire
generation like that you know anybody 35
and under right and so the thing is Jay
and David and Tony they have the
knowledge that you like you have the
knowledge but just zero exposure to this
generation like think they lost they
they got swept up and lost and now
YouTube influencers Fitness guys who
have done
a 100th of what you've done are the most
looked up to guys online giving them
wrong information sometimes right like
this is wrong right
and so the call that I was on with them
was well how do we get these guys to be
relevant to this generation yeah because
it's it's doing the work of building a
brand they don't read your your books
from 20 years or 30 years or four years
of publishing right and all these guys
care about their legacy and they're
pissed that with this generation is zero
name recognition tony is still out there
people still know Tony Asher is still
out there but he's still like going with
Robin Sharma Sharma is gone I mean I'm
talking his guys to like he's now trying
to leverage his abilities Tony's got
400,000 subs on YouTube which is great
like I have 1.3 million he should be I
don't deserve that compared to the the
knowledge set that I have compared to
like we should be way ahead of me right
not it's not even a contest and J and
David are non-existent like yeah not
known at all so there's an opportunity
right now in that the people who are the
experts the leaders don't know what
they're talking about compared to the
people who've been through the trenches
right so like the guys like you who
actually know like you're the best of
the best in your field but nobody knows
who you are and people are listening to
these Instagram models about how to
write it's like funeral so if the
biggest opportunity for you if you can
extend the runway to monetization is to
build the name brand that you are the
guy and you're posting everything for
free and you're the opportunity that
will come to you if you do this for the
next 24 months will be insane like
you'll have publishers throwing book
deals at you you don't have to worry
about writing the book and pitching the
publisher you'll be asked it to whatever
extent you want like I could be speaking
every weekend a different stage around
the world if I wanted to but I want to
be here with my wife and my son so I'm
like super selective over what I
if you wanted that career you could be
that career if you want to be an author
and do a book every six months like
Brian Tracy does that's an option if you
have the audience to pitch it to us your
child somebody knows you yeah right so
you're in the same boat as jay and david
bach and like all of these guys the old
guard will have all the experience and
you're good on camera it's like you have
to teach you how to okay it was like
here's a microphone you like don't be
nervous right like it's the same thing
for all these like perhaps they've been
doing it for decades right so there's an
opportunity right now and i feel it
because when we're trying to do these
compilations of people this is a lack of
quality information there's a lack of
quality people the real hope
[Music]
wish I had another hour
man
[Music]
I want good people to win I want good
people to win so badly I care more than
I should
my guy has so much talent and genius if
you just applied it for the next 16 to
24 months he'll be known around the
world and I'm pissed I didn't do enough
to pull him there I planted a seed but I
don't know if it's strong enough to make
him do it
I want people to win we're taking team
out for a walk in the rain because he
hasn't gone out today so that's the
entrepreneur life vlog has to go for a
walk next up we'll go into my dance
studio
China dance salsa we're doing an
interview with a blogger who wanted to
interview me for her her website or blog
and then we're gonna meet with one of
the people on my trial that sells a team
an assistant instructor helped her with
some whatever she wants talk about some
of her issues her life and that's going
to the next couple hours right now
chemos cooing and we got to pick that up
entrepreneur life right there why did I
buy this place so I was I was an
investor in it I believed in in kind of
the mission what we're trying to do the
owner wanted to leave the business she
wanted to move on to something else in
her career and nobody on the team was
ready or willing to take it over I
didn't want to see the company die that
was really the reason this is not a
typical ideal business for me it's very
local it's only in the city it's harder
to scale compared to an online company
it's harder to get the reach that I
would normally look for in an
opportunity that I'm targeting but it's
just too important to me you know I met
my wife through here lots of great
connections have happened here it's a
really important place for people and so
it was too important for me to allow to
die and so I said okay this is not what
I want to do but I'm gonna take it over
I then dedicated I spend all in probably
two business days a week I spend one day
on Mondays doing a lot of tedious work
mentoring Alex and then like you saw
today going back and forth of the daleks
giving feedback dealing with issues or
challenges that come out
so it's a lot of work and ultimately as
Alex gets better he's he's taking more
responsibilities I don't have to do as
much but it was really just a labor of
love this place is too important to the
community to allow to die and so I
decided I need to take it over
hi I'm Roxy I'm a blogger and a blogger
so today I am going to be interviewing
Evan about what it's like to be a
youtuber Evans done a bunch of collapse
with people I really look up to for
example Lewis house whose podcast I've
listened to a few times and just seeing
someone who's actually here in Toronto
to doing the same thing and like talking
about success and was like to have true
success and not just like success in one
party life so it was really cool so yeah
so just to kick off the interview look
at the organization I like that well
people love like schedules like yours
yeah yeah like you know in the business
that just helping people believe in
themselves and I'm trying to solve the
world's biggest problem untapped human
potential and YouTube is one of the ways
that I do it and part of what I love
doing is meeting up with fans and doing
interviews and spread and threaten the
love and the vibe and so pump to be here
and meet you guys and get asked some
tough questions hard-hitting here it
comes with Roxy I'm 39 almost now so I
don't I don't look backwards that much
with dates and numbers I started just to
give back just to help starting the
business was you know really hard for me
really demanding really kind of chewed
up my soul I was the most difficult time
personally in my life and just feeling
just self-worth being super low trying
to whole bunch of things and nothing
working
and that really sucked and so I wanted
to make it easier for other
entrepreneurs to not face the same
problems as I do and so I answered a
bunch of questions by emails I stood a
bunch of speaking and I thought hey next
time some of the answers are asking a
question how about I just make a video
about it and share some of that and so
that was the that was the start of my
youtube channel I was making a couple
videos answering questions I also
learned a lot from modeling successful
people so you know now we look at Drake
and but at the time I was looking at
Bill Gates or Oprah or Steve Jobs or
some of these Titans of their industry
and made quick videos on what we could
learn from them basically what I wished
existed you know like I wish somebody
else did it didn't exist so I made it
myself a little Butte College is going
to get down but if you love the process
yeah I'm just gonna keep grinding it out
for girls watch it there was a video
that I saw it was about like six months
ago on my channel that was old is like
four or five years old and I just got a
comment on it now like five years later
I got my first comment on that video
that might even 2018 right it's like
yeah thank you like going back on I
wasn't getting comments on my first
videos like every what we get hundreds
of day now but but every one comment
that I got was so it was fuels like
man's one person paid attention so I
think people just quit too soon I think
people expect them to get you expect to
get tons of views and tons of comments
and to blow up but it takes time to get
good at anything
[Music]
the best advice that I would give to
somebody entering the real world one I
would say recognize you're already in
the real world you already have a lot of
the skills a lot of the talents here
you're already facing a lot of the
challenges and the problems it's not all
that different than what you're what
you're really experiencing now I would
find the thing that that I'm curious
about and find the easiest way to get
started I think everybody should start a
YouTube channel I think everybody should
try to vlog I think everybody should try
sushi and Mexican food and like try you
gotta try you gotta say yes you got it
you got an experiment you get an idea
for something find a way to start this
is your time to experiment like if this
is the last vlog that you ever do great
like you tried it not feeling it awesome
move on so many people just think their
ways out of opportunities instead of
actually just going and testing it you
won't figure out what you're meant to do
by sitting on the couch you won't so you
got to go out and try it so as soon as
you get an idea for something I wish I
could blank like even ask yourself that
I wish I could right then just find the
smallest possible way to actually do
something about it today if you if you
constantly take that approach then
ultimately you'll find out the thing
that you were born to do we're meant to
do can have a huge impact on and you'll
take out you alright you go to the next
plug that's good that's great Congrats
vlog 2 in the books she's done no
problem
hey Karolina
how you doing so I'm a helper volunteer
here at CES and I occasionally assist
the main instructors guess he wanted to
discuss my business he's actually the
reason why I quit my business yeah oh
yeah that's what I do it was something I
had to do and that's what we were gonna
start discussing now that so at 18 I'm
gonna go like - too far back but it's
kind of why I started this whole
personal development and business and
all that yeah so at 18 I found myself
completely broke
okay I was a single mom back home here
oh yeah so I have my daughter at sorry
19 and I was really young and I was
really scared I became a mom really
young and I had to grow up really fast
so that brought on a ton of obstacles
and challenges in my life a lot of them
being
two challenges just being able to
support her and I was just in a really
dark place for a really long time
because I felt like I wasn't giving my
daughter the life that she deserved my
whole life I was told you know go to
school get good grades get a good job
and you know everything will be taken
care of and I did that you know I went
to school and worked really hard and I
got a corporate job I didn't like the
job that I was in at all I wasn't I
wasn't satisfied at all I hated it I
mean it was paying the bills barely but
it wasn't something I wanted to do and
one day I just kind of snapped and I
kind of just said enough like I was
tired of feeling the way I was feeling
in terms of low self-esteem in terms of
confidence in terms of not feeling like
I was living a fulfilled happy life so I
wanted time freedom I wanted my time
back I wanted to be able to provide more
I guess material things for my daughter
be able to travel more and things like
that and I started blush with media
which is a consultant consultancy
business for personal trainers and there
was one conversation you and I had that
kind of sparked up the whole behavior so
I wouldn't judge everything myself man
he reached out to me on social media and
the conversation of my business came up
and and he asked me you know why why
personal training why
my ministry on Facebook and I just you
know the answers I was coming up with
was because I had experience in the past
I worked for a gym before and I sort of
understood the industry and I did very
well in sales and I figured you know
what I was good at it I could build off
of that and start making some great
money and I was you know I'll be able to
be my own boss and make my own schedules
and I had the ability to be with my
daughter more not miss so many things
and and things like that and and I think
Evan from the very beginning knew that
it was a logical choice and not so much
a decision I had made from my heart it
wasn't a decision to start the business
because I was super passionate about the
service I was providing for you know my
potential clients it was all logical
there was always something I wanted to
do but I always felt like it was stupid
and I always felt like I had to deny
myself that because I thought that my
place was a you know a big office or
something or you know having this title
that sounded great dancing it was
dancing I know a guy yeah what about you
know jackass I'm solid and every we met
one day and Evans like you know what do
you what do you get lost in and the very
first thing that came who has always
been dancing and ever since I was young
I was just like man I wish I could do
this every single day yeah set that
burns me just this the
the I care more than I should like that
impacts me personally knowing that she
was in a spot that I felt that that I
didn't push her harder on it
one of the rules that I try to live by
is when I'm 80 85 percent sure that I'm
a hundred percent sure because you never
100% sure every decision you can only be
a hundred percent sure once it happens
you get the results otherwise you're
projecting forward so when I'm 85
percent then I have to act like 100
and the confidence and conviction pulls
people through that you can do this that
I have absolute clarity and confidence
around it inspires confidence in the
other person if I'm doubting it if I
allow the fifteen percent to get the
better of me and then the person who I'm
trying to help won't believe it
should I have pushed her more that I do
my best that I give my best to her when
I had the opportunity to help her get
the result that she wants
I think
[Music]
so I think that the way to build a
meaningful connection with someone is to
share and be open about your hopes and
your dreams and your fears and your
doubts when you create a safe space
where you can share those things you
give permission to other people to share
and be vulnerable and be open like with
anyone that you deeply love or care
about they know your deep dark secrets
as much as your hopes and dreams but
there's a sense of trust right they
earned that so here's my story before I
started telling in my classes about my
operation about the sweating right that
I that I have scars on my body and that
I was super uncomfortable and I've been
bullied since I was 11 or 12 I wanted to
test it out by sharing with a total
stranger because I'm like if I can
pretty much share with a stranger that I
can share with the class right because
I'm honestly worried about being judged
like oh you're so weak or you're still
dumb above all of this so I made a
decision to share with Evan so the
school owner Evans videographer not
these two guys another videographer so I
come in to the studio he's not there and
I see his name is Jason so I see him and
I'm a Jason I want to tell you something
and I'm like sweating profusely like I
am so nervous except my hands cuz my
hands you know because I the operation
in my hands can sweat but my body's
really sweaty and I'm like hey Jason so
I did this thing operation you know I
had this complex and buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
this literally the thing that came out
of his mouth was you have a scar and I'm
like what he's like you have a scar I'm
like yeah I got a scar he said cuz I
have scars from her operation so he
lifts up his shirt he's showing me his
scars on his body but no way that kind
of looks like mine and I lift up my
shirt
we have our shirts half off the owner
comes in he's like what are you doing
and I'm like we're bonding leave us
alone
like what is that kind of like and like
as the craziness is as as I let myself
get into that by being vulnerable we
became really really good friends and
like I learned from that like I had like
before that I've met him I've talked to
him but it's always been like Oh what
kind of movies have you seen Bob about
like meaningless you know not real
significant conversations as soon as I
started opening up he start opening up
and that's I think how you build
meaningful conversation that's what I
want for you there's a friendship if
there's something that you want to build
at work or whatever lead by example and
share your hopes and your dreams and
your doubts and you create a safe space
for others to do that too the reason I
talked about this cuz believe it
when I was in a stripper I first became
an instructor I was really really lonely
so I was part of TDS I knew everybody I
knew all the helpers but I didn't know
anybody because every time I would stand
outside with them talking we'd be
talking about what Lily they watched or
what do they you know what deficit they
but papaya or whatever and just I'd have
meaningless conversations and I kept
leaving those conversations and I kept
feeling like I don't know anybody like I
feel like I don't have a connection with
anybody and what I did was I forced
myself every time I talked to them to
have real conversations I'm like hey how
was your day what did you do that we
really enjoy because what I did was this
and as I was just opening up more and I
let those space in for people to be
vulnerable themselves and through that
with Katarina with Irina and like all
the helpers Peter like I started really
connecting with him and I think that
leading by example and letting yourself
be vulnerable first you give permission
to other people to open up right you
don't have to always wait for someone to
open up to you if you open up you give
primis you say yes and that's what I
want for you if there's anyone at work
at you're alone whatever you want to
build a connection with lead by example
let yourself be vulnerable share your
hopes and dreams and that's going to
give them the permission to do the same
and that's what I want for you I want
you to have more meaningful
conversations and relationships from
life bring it in guys I love you there
you go there it's still warm
all right so great to see Alex in action
hopefully you guys got a little bit of a
sense of the vibe and the fun that we do
the speech that he was practicing this
morning with me there's some footage of
you guys checked out earlier on it was
pretty good he's getting there the
emotion is slowly picking up people are
slamming what happened there the motion
is picking up it's still a little bit
rushed he's still kind of slimming
through it and so when you can slow that
down really connect with the message I
think it's gonna have any bigger impact
that's always been intention to go for
education entertainment and then up to a
halt so that people
and leaving the studio so it's getting
there it's getting there with Mara
hustle hard work dedication practice
it'll be even better that's a day in the
life you know this class is gonna go on
until 10 o'clock I might hang out give
Alex some feedback on how it can improve
and that's a not so typical Thursday all
the time for me but in general that's a
day in my life it's working it's being
the entrepreneur having meetings pushing
people seeing how I can stretch my brand
and have an impact and who you guys
enjoy being the part of the process well
let me know what you think about this
style of video it's a new experiment for
me you guys are testing out if you like
it leave a comment below give us
feedback how we can improve it for the
next time around thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details